it's been four years and apple finally
announced the redesigned macbook air
with a ton of updates and changes at its
2022 wdc event they showed it off and
gave us some key specs but there's still
a lot of things that they conveniently
didn't mention both good bad and
disappointing in this video i'm not just
going to rehash the event like many
people do but provide some key insights
that you likely won't hear anywhere else
after this launch so make sure to watch
the whole thing of course we're going to
be buying it actually we're gonna get
multiple configurations and we're gonna
share real world detailed testing and
comparisons now we'll also be putting
out a buyer's guide on the specific
upgrades that are worth buying and what
you should avoid so make sure to click
that subscribe button down below and
with that you can help us reach our goal
of 1 million subscribers we are so so
close the new m2 macbook air redesign is
based off of the 14 and 16 inch macbook
pros and we have four color options
silver space gray just like before as
well as the new starlight and midnight
colors just like you get with the apple
watch series 7 and the iphone 13s
personally i am disappointed that gold
is gone it was by far my favorite color
not only for macbooks but also for
iphones and the apple watch so it sucks
that it's gone and the new starlight is
more of a warm champagne color kind of a
mix of silver and rose gold now i'm not
a fan at all and i would rather just
have gold in or maybe just even get the
silver one instead but you guys let me
know your thoughts down in the comment
section below now i like the midnight
color a lot more it kind of can look
like black under certain lighting but
it's a deep navy blue it's basically
kind of like a darker space gray but
with a slight blue tint a lot of people
have been asking for a black macbook and
i don't know if apple will ever offer
that but this is the closest that we've
ever gotten i'm a fan and i'll be
ordering this one but you guys let me
know your thoughts down below as for the
design for the first time ever the air
doesn't have a macbook air name on the
display chin just like the new macbook
pros don't but what's interesting is
that unlike those that instead have the
logo on the bottom this one has a
completely flat smooth bottom so it
literally has no macbook air branding on
it at all as far as connections we have
the headphone jack still on the right
side but now it's support for higher end
headphones and two usb type-c ports on
the left with a new max a3 connector as
well that comes with color matching
cables and plugs unlike the 16-inch
macbook pros where you still got a
silver cable with the space gray model
now for the first set of disappointing
things that they didn't mention they
showed off the magsafe connection and
the ability to fast charge 50 in 30
minutes while audibly saying that you
will need an available 67 watt power
adapter but when showing off the really
cool 35 watt dual usb type c port
compact adapter they didn't say that you
will have to pay extra for that why not
ditch the old 30 watt adapter all
together and give us this compact one in
the box which can modulate power between
two devices for maximum charging speed
well that is because apple wants to
maximize their profits and they will
charge you an extra twenty dollars to
get this new charger now thankfully they
do give you tips on how to get it as a
free upgrade but you'll have to buy the
1500 model to get it now the next thing
is even more disappointing because you
can't just pay 20 bucks to fix it and
that is the performance of the ports
apple's latest macs have come with
thunderbolt 4 which is more powerful but
looking at the key specs after the wwdc
event we see that this 2022 macbook air
comes with the same thunderbolt 3 ports
that the m1 macbook air came with and
not thunderbolt 4 like the 14 and 16
inch macbook pros along with the mac
studio now we'll see if these two ports
have separate controllers when we get
them so make sure to enable those
notifications but for most people what
will matter is the biggest limitation
that apple didn't talk about and that is
only support for one external display
yes probably the biggest complaint is
still there and we now know that it
wasn't just a limitation of apple's
first apple silicon chip the m1 but an
intentional choice to force people to
spend more money and buy a 14-inch
macbook pro for two thousand dollars if
they want to connect to more than one
display and that is a big bummer of
course you could use an external adapter
or docs like anker's new one that gives
support for up to three displays i'll go
ahead and link it down below in the
description so you guys can check it out
the included display is a slightly
larger 13.6 inch screen so the new notch
isn't technically wasting any space but
you actually get a little bit more and
it's now 25 brighter at 500 nits instead
of 400 so you no longer lose out on
brightness compared to the macbook pro
we also have the way better 1080p webcam
from the high-end macbook pros which is
a big upgrade but you can make it even
better by using your iphone on your
macbook as you can see we do have black
bezels instead of the long leaked white
ones let me know below if you're happy
that they went with black ones or if you
wish they would have the off-white ones
from the 24-inch imac now even though
this looks like a 14-inch macbook pro we
do have some differences we no longer
have speaker cutouts on the sides of the
keyboards but instead the speakers are
hidden above the keyboard apple has done
this before with a random macbook and it
still sounded good and they say that
these speakers are better than the m1
airs which they definitely will be
because we have four speakers instead of
two now one thing they didn't mention is
if these are dedicated
deep woofers now we have to assume so
because there are two larger drivers but
on their website they only list four
speakers whereas the 14 and 16 inch
models specifically list high fidelity
speakers with woofers in the video the
bottom speakers are much larger and of
course they do have to produce bass but
this could just mean that they won't
have that rich and deep bass that the
better macbook pros have now that is
totally fine we'll just have to see how
much of an upgrade this is in our
upcoming m1 versus m2 macbook air
comparison now you would think that they
got rid of the speaker grille because of
the smaller size and weight apple
mentioned a 20 reduction in volume
compared to the m1 model but what they
didn't say is that the footprint is
actually now larger let me explain the
m2 model is thinner coming in at only
0.44 inches thin that is crazy thin but
they didn't say that the width is
actually exactly the same and in terms
of depth the new macbook air is actually
longer than the previous one so the 20
reduction in size is only because of the
thinness and that also helps with weight
coming in at 2.7 pounds instead of 2.8
now despite that the battery has
actually gotten bigger coming in at 52.6
watt hours instead of 49.9 so just over
five percent larger apple showed off 18
hours of video playback which they test
using the apple tv app with downloaded
content but as far as wireless web usage
the site lists the same 15 hours as
before now that is interesting because
the new m2 chip is more efficient as
they shut off on stage and the four
efficiency cores are a lot more powerful
which means that the performance ones
will need to be used less often now of
course real world battery life could
actually be better
than the previous one they also didn't
mention that this new m2 chip didn't get
any updates in terms of wireless
connectivity sticking with the same
bluetooth 5.0 and wi-fi 6 and a lot of
people were hoping for updates to catch
up with the competition with wi-fi 6e
and better bluetooth but nope we are not
getting it here but at least the new
macbook air is now able to be configured
up to 24 gigabytes of ram for 200 more
than the 16 gigabyte model now they
definitely could have done a 32 gigabyte
configuration like some people asked for
but it seems like they are keeping that
exclusive for the 14 inch lineup because
even the m2 macbook pro can't get this
option like the older intel models could
we know that the redesigned macbook air
costs 200 more than the m1 model which
is still being sold but when they showed
off the m2 chip with the 10 core
graphics they didn't mention that for
the 200 price jump you still don't get
that 10 cores but instead you get a
binned eight core model to get the full
35 increase of graphics performance with
the m2 you need to spend an additional
for the two extra graphics scores
bringing you up to thirteen hundred
dollars the same amount as the m2
macbook pro of course the m2 pro has
that additional fan to make sure that
you're having full performance with no
slow downs and that's included for that
300 bucks and also it does come with
that faster 67 watt charging for the
fast charging now we'll be doing an m2
macbook air versus an m2 mac pro full
comparison video as well as a deep dive
into the m2 chip all the new
improvements and some of the other
limitations so if you guys want to see
that make sure you guys click that
subscribe button right above check out
one of those great videos right over
there i'm super excited to be making
more content on these machines and doing
deep um very good testing for you guys
this has been max and i'll see you in
the next video
[Music]